now she is receiving rave reviews with a
capital R for her new film it's called
the inspection it's based on the true
story the film's director and writer his
name is Elegance Bratton so the movie
focuses on Ellis French a young gay man
who joins the Marines during the
military militaries don't ask don't tell
error Union portrays French's homophobic
mother Inez in this preview Inez
confronts her son after he asked for his
birth certificate or his military
application here's a look
slow
piece of paper
it's all I have left of
the dream I held for you
[Music]
if you don't come back the sun I gave
birth to
consider this certificate void
oh that movie was tough Gabrielle Union
is also executive producer of the film
we welcome you thank you we're so glad
to have you in studio Gabrielle Union
now Elegance came to you because he
wanted you to be the executive executive
producer and then he asked you to star
in it and you balked it first he clearly
saw something in you that you didn't
even see in yourself absolutely what was
it he said he's like it absolutely has
to be you we've known you could do this
the whole time
and immediately I knew what he was
talking about he's like in the black
community we've we know you have range
don't get it messed up if they don't see
it I see it and I know you can do this
um he's like but it has to be you and I
didn't know what that meant at the time
um but he had such a huge level of
confidence in me that it became
contagious and I was like yeah
but you say this you said it came at a
time when you had low self-esteem about
the industry low self-esteem about who
you are as an actress a human and being
a mom yes what do you mean Gabrielle I
think you know when you're constantly
being barraged by images of perfection
everyone's Perfection right you start
feeling like I'm not I'm not adding up
it's not adding up I'm not keeping up
um in any capacity in my life I just
feel like I'm underwater in every area
of my life and I'm I'm drowning
um
so for for a man like Elegance to have
that kind of confidence in me was really
my needed boost yeah um and not just in
Hollywood but in my life it was it
started me on the on the path of trying
to figure out what kind of woman I want
to be for the next 50 60 years yeah
thanks for that transparency a lot of
people can identify with that it does
take somebody telling us you know how to
swim for you to figure it out
um you say that you had to find the
humanity in on his character how did you
do that and was it difficult yeah I had
to do a lot of research I had to do
um
just a huge deep dive and not just into
who this woman was it's a real person
that's a daunting task in and of itself
but I had to go inside myself to find
her humanity and try to figure out at
what point do we intersect what can I
relate you know to about this woman that
I generally speaking don't tend to find
a lot of positive out of you know folks
that behave like this you couldn't be
more different right I mean in your real
life your your lgbtq Advocate as a
mother as a person in the world and this
is a mother who is so staunchly against
the LGBT community that she's rejecting
her own son her own child well I think
oh gosh it's awful so opposite of who
you are and what you believe yeah and
when you're so focused on the the world
thinking you're good and a good mother
uh you'll you'll be willing to barter
with anything just to be thought of as
good worthy deserving you get on that
assimilation training you don't know
when to get off and you next thing you
know you've hit a brick wall and like is
over and you've been shape-shifting and
tap dancing your whole life and you know
for people who wouldn't spit in your
direction if you were on fire but
Gabriel but that's what I had in common
with her I wanted that I wanted that
kind of deep validation from the world
right and uh that was how I got into the
character that kind of sameness that
Darkness does live within most of us and
I found that Darkness Within Myself it
wouldn't spit on you if you were on fire
yeah that they really don't like you
when they're behaving that way but let's
talk about the rave reviews that you're
getting in this role honestly they're
well deserved well-deserved start
turning oscar-worthy do you see yourself
differently after playing this character
has it changed how you feel and see
yourself as an actress absolutely how so
once I was able to to deliver
you know I mean like I'm I'm an athlete
you know I come from an athletic
background right so it's either you do
it or you don't yeah you know what I
mean either you won or you lost I'm very
black and white about that so by the
last scene because we kind of shot it
sort of in order uh the last scene was
you know
um I'm never giving up on you uh-huh and
when when that ended and I got back to
my room
damn right but I gave myself permission
to dream of other roles I always kind of
play things that are closer to me
because it's easier it's safer my good
friend Sanaa Lathan she said 20 years
ago baby if it doesn't scare you it's
not worth doing I thought well that's a
terrible route I'm like I want to do
things that make me comfortable don't
you think people see you differently too
immediately immediately immediately as
soon as the the movie ended in Toronto
at the Toronto Film Festival the calls
coming into my team were different like
I'm not even up to audition for roles
like this it's not even like I have the
opportunity to try and fail right you're
on certain lists I I'm just not on the
serious actress list I'm you know when I
was just thinking of myself as a
producer on this right my list of people
who would play Inez I I wasn't on that
list I didn't see it in myself well I'm
glad Elegance convinced you I'm so glad
because you knocked it out of the park
and I can't wait when the Oscar
nominations come out to see what you're
going to wear that's what I say yeah I'm
gonna put it out there in the universe
talk about it claiming it congrats
congrats and our best to Dwyane Wade who
who tattooed your initials on it finally
I was like okay like okay I get Martin
Luther I get that I came after Martin
Luther King but every number that you've
ever worn in life like including like
AAU and Pop Warner like can I be like
the 17th tattoo and he got a tiny little
one so where's where's this where's his
tattoo at oh his is oh of me never oh
okay it's right here this is it okay
this is it I couldn't even get a second
ear pierced I was like that's too risque
congratulations to you and our best of
Mr Wade Gabrielle Union's movie is
called the inspection Jeremy Pope also
was here knockout in this is in theaters
now wherever you like to go we'll be
right back